este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
silver gosht vpn vpn es tu mejor aliado
brindando de seguridad cuando usas redes
wifi wifi públicas en cafeterías teles
aeropuertos o permitiéndote también
acceder a contenido en la red que no
está disponible en tu país en tu área
geográfica bien pues aquí saber ghost
vpn es donde entra en juego saber coste
vpn se puede usar en todas las
plataformas windows macos ios android
android tv
amazon fire stick linux y hasta en
routers y con una suscripción puedes
proteger hasta 7 dispositivos al mismo
tiempo creo que ni yo tengo siete
dispositivos vamos que de sobra cuenta
además con un servicio de atención al
cliente 24 horas los 7 días de la semana
si cambiara de opinión tienes 45 días
para pedir el reembolso sobrecoste vpn
es una compañía con 15 años de
antigüedad y con más de 30 millones de
usuarios alrededor
del mundo poseen más de 5 mil 500
servidores vpn localizados en 90 países
y tiene una política estricta de no
almacenar registros ve a saber ghost vpn
puntocom barra visual política y obtén
un 77 por ciento de descuento por ser
miembro de la comunidad de visual
política obtén silver gosht vpn por tan
sólo 275 euros al mes y entra ahora en
esta dirección para una oferta de
navidad especial para toda la comunidad
de visual política el plan de 18 meses
cuesta sólo 275 euros al mes te dejo en
la descripción el link desde donde
registrarte importante sólo podrás
obtener el descuento a través de esta
dirección y ahora vayamos con el vídeo
de hoy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y corea del norte no sería un país tan
conocido si no fuera por sus pruebas
nucleares su tiránico y extravagante
gobierno hoy por hoy la peor dictadura
del planeta y por sus sonadas salidas de
tono insultando a líderes
internacionales sobre todo de eeuu
hablamos en la práctica de un país pobre
un país de algo más de 25 millones de
habitantes sin ninguna industria y
comercio relevante y un poder
adquisitivo por los suelos
sin embargo amigos corea del norte ha
sido es y será un protagonista destacado
en muchos foros y cumbres
internacionales por sus constantes
violaciones de los derechos humanos y su
avanzado programa nuclear y balístico
pues bien el caso es que el 2019 ha sido
un año especialmente complicado para su
dictador kim jong-un y el 2020 no se
presenta mucho mejor
[Música]
junto a los efectos de las sanciones
internacionales para importar materiales
y productos de todo tipo el país
atraviesa una dura situación alimentaria
por la sequía las inundaciones y otras
circunstancias que han hecho que las
cosechas hayan caído a mínimos de 5 años
generando una usada escasez de alimentos
a casi el 40% de los norcoreanos eso
supone más de 10 millones de personas a
las que el estado no les puede
garantizar unos mínimos nutricionales 10
millones de personas que quedan al
amparo de la asistencia humanitaria
internacional
corea del sur por ejemplo les ha
ofrecido 50.000 toneladas de arroz para
paliar el hambre sin embargo a pesar de
esta difícil situación lo cierto es que
la economía norcoreana como ya os hemos
contado aquí en visual político lleva
años creciendo de una forma un tanto
extraña informal caótica de la mano en
gran medida del mercado negro pero lo
cierto es que la economía norcoreana ha
registrado los últimos años ciertos
avances
[Aplausos]
hablamos de un crecimiento económico
irregular pero que según se estima
algunos años habría promediado un ritmo
del 5 por ciento anual
[Música]
pero obviamente hablamos de tasas de
crecimiento que parten de una situación
de pobreza extrema y que solo ha
alcanzado a determinados núcleos urbanos
[Música]
el 40 por ciento de los norcoreanos que
viven en las áreas rurales no tienen ni
siquiera garantizado el suministro
eléctrico el crecimiento y sobre todo
las inversiones del gobierno norcoreano
tan solo se aprecian en reductos muy
limitados como por ejemplo pyongyang y
otras ciudades secundarias como wonsan
sinuiju razón os antillón en el resto
del país básicamente la gente tiene que
salir a cortar los pocos árboles que
quedan en la radicalmente deforestada
corea del norte para poder calentarse en
invierno en casa con la madera es una
imagen una realidad que contrasta con
esta otra
[Música]
esta amigos es la nueva pyongyang que
está tratando de construir el régimen
norcoreano y no sólo hablamos de
pyongyang durante los últimos años se
han impulsado macro proyectos que no se
concentran sólo en la capital
y proyectos respecto a los que la
comunidad internacional se hace una
pregunta son fruto de la megalomanía de
kim jong-un un joven fue el dictador que
creció estudiando en colegios privados
en suiza y viendo partidos de la nba o
son por contra las muestras de que el
gobierno quiere cambiar de rumbo no lo
sabemos pero en este vídeo os vamos a
contar cuáles son los principales macro
proyectos norcoreanos y prestar atención
porque creo que os puede sorprender
vamos allá por cierto si quieres saber
de dónde obtiene el gobierno norcoreano
los recursos para todos estos proyectos
no te pierdas los vídeos que os dejo en
la descripción
[Música]
pyongyang del gris estalinista al metal
humanismo multicolor amigos amigas
cuando pensamos en pyongyang puede que a
la mayoría lo único que se nos venga a
la cabeza sea el esqueleto de aquel
hotel gigantesco con forma de pirámide
que costó dios y ayuda a completar
[Música]
un esqueleto que durante ni más ni menos
que dieciséis años no vio ni a un solo
trabajador entre los años 1992 y el 2008
el edificio estuvo totalmente paralizado
simple y llanamente porque el gobierno
norcoreano carecía de recursos para
completarlo
[Música]
primero como consecuencia de la caída de
la unión soviética y después por los
efectos de la ardua marcha una hambruna
que se llevó a más de dos millones de
personas por delante sin embargo tuvo
que llegar kim jong-un para terminarlo
hablamos de un edificio llamado a ser
uno de los grandes emblemas del régimen
cuya construcción puso en marcha a kim
il-sung el abuelo de la dinastía qin que
estuvo todo el gobierno de kim jong-il
sin terminarse y que ahora kim jong-un
ha recubierto de cristal y de una
pantalla gigante
[Música]
eso sí por dentro no se sabe muy bien
qué es lo que hay porque de lo que se
dice un hotel no parece desde su
finalización en 2016 que se sepa todavía
no ha entrado ni un solo huésped vamos
que estamos ante un decorado de primera
[Música]
pero no penséis ni por un momento que
éste es el único macroproyecto inútil
esperar a ver lo que se ha levantado en
pyongyang en los últimos años y lo que
está por venir
[Música]
ahí tenemos por ejemplo la calle de los
científicos mire qué significa futuro en
coreano es una calle de rascacielos
residenciales tiendas y restaurantes de
comida coreana y comida internacional
esta avenida se abrió como premio para
los científicos del programa nuclear y
también para profesores universitarios
muy atentos al régimen cuenta con un
control de acceso para coches que lo
convierte en una especie de barrio
exclusivo clases sociales quien ha dicho
clases sociales
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y no sólo eso también está la más
reciente la avenida reunión inaugurada
en abril de 2017 con casi 20 rascacielos
residenciales muchos de ellos con
colores azules y turquesas pintados y
mucho muchísimo azulejos para tratar de
imitar el color del cristal de los
modernos rascacielos de sus vecinos
corea del sur y china
[Música]
que os guste o no eso ya lo dejo al
parecer de cada uno pero un poco
fantasmagórico sí que resulta no me
negaréis ahora bien exactamente cuál es
el objetivo real de estos proyectos pues
veréis estamos ante un objetivo doble
uno local y otro internacional
[Música]
en local es el mensaje que kim jong-un
ha querido trasladar a la cúpula de
poder norcoreana en sus primeros años
como líder kim quiere decir que es joven
sí pero que con él el país se
modernizará se desarrollará y se
transformará sin importar lo que venga
de fuera y en cierto modo esta es la
mejor noticia para la comunidad
internacional un aparente espíritu de
cambio aunque la verdad es que derrochar
recursos en proyectos tan estériles no
parece la mejor forma de conseguirlo
pero es que por otro lado quien
construye todas estas obras que no se
puede permitir para consolidar su poder
adicional al mundo una cosa algo así
como oye mira ya podéis ponerme todas
las sanciones del mundo que aquí el
socialismo norcoreano está fuerte y
resistirá
este es el mensaje que sostiene a kim en
el poder el golpe de pecho frente a
occidente aunque sólo sea aparentando
ser algo que realmente no es
[Música]
en cualquier caso lo que parece claro es
que esta especie de época dorada para
pyongyang va a continuar en el tiempo
kim jong-un acaba de presentar en 2019
un nuevo macro proyecto para cambiar
completamente el barrio que rodea al
hotel fantasma corea del centro
televisión revela planes a gran escala
para el distrito que rodea el icónico
reunión pero espera un momento hasta
ahora solo os hemos hablado de la
capital de pyongyang pero qué está
pasando fuera de esta está que un
potenciando también este tipo de
proyectos fuera del gigantesco decorado
capitalino pues lo cierto es que sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es más los proyectos más locos se están
llevando a cabo fuera de la capital
hablamos sobre todo the sun y jong y la
península de calma en la ciudad de
wonsan
[Música]
pero si ya lo voy a venir estaréis
pensando a ver alberto qué narices son
estos lugares pues lo cierto es que
hasta ahora no eran nada nada relevante
pero kim como buen niño de papá educado
en suiza quería tener su propia versión
de una estación de esquí al estilo
europeo y también ya ha puesto su propia
ciudad de vacaciones para el verano y
eso eso es exactamente lo que está
haciendo
[Música]
el objetivo supuestamente y llenar de
turismo un país que en 2018 recibió una
cifra récord de 12 millones de turistas
chinos un 50 por ciento más que en 2017
y junto a ellos también algún que otro
puñado de turistas de otras
nacionalidades por supuesto todos
debidamente acompañados por guías que
les controlan en todo momento
pero si la fiebre por el turismo parece
estar llegando hasta la mismísima corea
del norte os gustaría conocer mejor la
apuesta definitiva de kim por conseguir
la divisa extranjera que tanto necesita
tras las sanciones pues atentos
[Música]
dos nuevas ciudades para el invierno y
el verano
para conseguir convertir a corea del
norte en algo así como la tailandia del
noreste asiático kim jong-un está
gastándose un montón de dinero en crear
complejos turísticos haber un montón de
dinero teniendo en cuenta la realidad
del país claro el de sabillón y el de
calma son dos de los mayores ejemplos
[Música]
pampillón es un polo localizado a las
faldas del monte para que tú que según
la tradición coreana donde se fundó
corea y que según la historieta
propagandística norcoreana es también
donde nació kim jong-il mientras los
pajarillos cantaban y salía un brillante
arco iris por el horizonte
[Música]
y el caso es que hoy por hoy esta región
se conoce más por ser uno de los parajes
naturales más bellos del país y también
por tener unas condiciones fantásticas
para los deportes de invierno y ahí
precisamente ahí kim jong-un quiso
construir su suiza en miniatura
[Música]
por eso ordenó derribar el pueblo entero
y construir otro nuevo con un gran hotel
tiendas bloques de apartamentos y casas
con tejados de colores para albergar a
cuatro mil familias 380 edificios
públicos e industriales como no unas
cuantas pistas de esquí todo esto se ha
construido en un año y medio claro que
cuando miramos entre bastidores la
historia nos resulta tan bonita
[Música]
para poder construirlo el régimen
empleado mano de obra semiesclava y al
mismísimo ejército los trabajadores
forzados han sido movilizados desde los
campos de trabajo forzosos y ha habido
que pinchar suplementos de electricidad
dejando sin energía a multitud de
pueblos de alrededor y todo esto para
poder terminarlo según lo previsto en el
primer trimestre de 2020 para poder
aprovechar la campaña invernal de este
año porque si algo le hace falta aquí es
pasta dólares euros yenes yuanes divisas
quizás con un poco de suerte algún chino
vaya a tirarse por sus pistas de esquí y
alojarse en alguno de sus desangelados
alojamientos sea como sea sand guillón
ha sido vendido por el régimen como la
utopía socialista la demostración de que
el régimen puede crear un paraíso
invernal sin embargo martha thorne
directora ejecutiva del prestigioso
premio pritzker de arquitectura no lo
tiene tan claro fijaos no es más que una
simple estación de esquí no refleja las
nuevas formas de vivir pone poco énfasis
en la calidad urbana y en el uso del
suelo público y no proyecta espacios
donde las personas puedan desarrollar
una vida plena pero bueno más allá de
estas disquisiciones sobre urbanismo y
del hecho de que económicamente parezca
poco viable sabillón es a día de hoy uno
de los mejores lugares dentro del peor
lugar del planeta la duda ahora es si
esto mismo lo van a reproducir en calma
en la ciudad de wonsan lo que allí se
está construyendo nada tiene que ver con
la gélida sant billón hablamos de una
verdadera ciudad de vacaciones para el
verano
[Música]
consiste en casi cinco kilómetros de
extremo a extremo de edificios que están
construyendo todos a la vez todo esto
con un aeropuerto recién remodelado y
una hermosa y reluciente terminal pero a
la que no vuela nadie quien yo no quiere
que esto sea el cancún del mar del este
la cartagena de indias norcoreana el
marina d'or comunista
la magnitud del proyecto lo convierte
quizás en la salvajada más cara de la
última década para la paupérrima corea
del norte
hablamos de 12 hoteles 2 centros
comerciales 26 edificios para tiendas
fin es un palacio de exhibición es un
edificio de juegos arcade un parque
acuático cubierto una pista de patinaje
sobre hielo un complejo de restaurantes
y más de 48 mansiones y 200 chalés de
lujo para alojarse
todo esto en un país cerrado al mundo y
anclado en la pobreza extrema donde gran
parte de la población tiene problemas
para alcanzar los nutrientes mínimos
necesarios
evidentemente no hay ni que decirlo todo
esto no va a ser disfrutado por
cualquiera las élites del país los altos
funcionarios y quizás algún que otro
turista serán quienes disfruten de todos
estos servicios y el resto pues
evidentemente no
pero no creáis que aquí se acaba todo
porque además de en pyongyang sabillón
igual son otras ciudades como sinuiju en
la frontera con china están viendo
cierto boom inmobiliario
[Música]
ahí nos encontramos por ejemplo con la
construcción de este hotel con forma de
sol en el distrito de carmen un lugar
pensado para alojar a hombres de
negocios una vez se active la zona
económica especial entre corea del norte
y china ahora paralizada por las
sanciones internacionales
[Música]
la idea de que ibas a formar todo el
frente ribereño del río yalú no solo
para explotar la creciente actividad
económica que se está gestando en esta
zona gracias al comercio con china y al
mercado negro del que el propio gobierno
es partícipe sino también para quienes
del otro lado donde se encuentra la
próspera acción china de dandong no se
vean solo miserables edificios que
parecen estar a punto de caerse sino un
espejismo de desarrollo y prosperidad
[Música]
amigos ahora que ya conocéis los
principales macro proyectos en los que
está inmersa corea del norte hay algo
muy importante que hay que dejar claro
todos estos proyectos pueden parecernos
una muestra de desarrollo sin embargo la
realidad es distinta
en la mayoría de los casos este tipo de
proyectos terminan vacíos simple y
llanamente porque no hay gente a la que
atender ni clientes que vayan a consumir
si no se abre al mundo de una forma
radical en común estaría mal gastando
cientos de millones de dólares que
podrían ser utilizados para cosas mucho
más necesarias como por ejemplo mejorar
las paupérrimas infraestructuras del
país
sí
para que os hagáis una idea de los más
de 25 mil 500 kilómetros de carreteras
que hay por todo el país tan solo 800
están asfaltados apenas un 3% también
son recursos que se podrían gastar en
represas canalizaciones y diques para
evitar inundaciones cuando llueve mucho
y tener también reservas de agua que
evitarán las recurrentes sequías y por
tanto el hambre
[Música]
o por ejemplo todo este mineral se
podría gastar también en impulsar de una
vez por todas la producción eléctrica ya
que la mayor parte del país se queda a
oscuras de noches
pero claro dónde va a parar una estación
de esquí o una ciudad de vacaciones son
cosas mucho más chic en fin qué os
parece creéis que el país en general
podrá beneficiarse de todos estos
proyectos turísticos como podrán llenar
esos hoteles mientras corea del norte
siga siendo un lugar tan reprimido que
ni siquiera existe la libertad de
moverse sin un guía
dejadnos vuestras impresiones en los
comentarios y si este vídeo os ha
ayudado a descubrir una nueva faceta de
corea del norte no olvides darle al
botón de like gracias por estar ahí y
recordad si no queréis que vuestro
dinero acabe financiando macroproyectos
en corea del norte usar silver gosht vpn
para conectarnos de forma segura a
internet un saludo y hasta la próxima